MARK: HELLO AMERICA, I AM
MARK LEVIN, THIS IS "LIFE,
LIBERTY AND LEVIN."
WE HAVE TWO GREAT GUESTS
HOUSE REPUBLICAN LEADER
KEVIN McCARTHY, AND
MR. MEDIA JOE CONCHA.
BEFORE THAT I WANT TO TALK
TO BUT A FEW THINGS,
DEMOCRAT PARTY DOESN'T WANT
TO TALK ABOUT INFLATION,
IMMIGRATION OR FOOD PRICES
OR GASOLINE PRICES OR CRIME.
THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT
RACE.
AND TO TALK ABOUT ABORTION.
LET'S TALK ABOUT RACE AND
ABORTION.
IT IS TIME FOR A TRUE
DISCUSSION.
NOT THE LIES WE GET FROM
MEDIA AND TENURED LEFTISTS
AND THE REST.
TALK ABOUT THE FACTS, I
WON'T GO TO CIVIL WAR, WHERE
DEMOCRAT PARTY WAS TIED TO
HIP WITH CONFEDERACY, AND
DAVIS OF A DEMOCRAT,.
NO.
I WON'T GO TO PLESSY
VERSUS FERGUSON BUT I WILL
GO TO WOODROW WILSON, ONE OF
THE GREAT SO-CALLED LEADING
PROGRESSIVE INTELLECTUALS IN
LATE 1800S AND 1900S
PRESIDENT OF PRINCETON
UNIVERSITY, GOVERNOR OF NEW
JERSEY AND ELECTED PRESIDENT
OF UNITED STATES, AND HE
OVERTURNED EVERY MAJOR
PRO-INTEGRATION LAW THAT WAS
PUT IN PLACE BY THE
REPUBLICANS WHO PRECEDED
HIM.
RECESSION GATED THE
DEPARTMENTS OF FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, FIRED BLACK
FORWARD ADMINISTRATE HOURS,
AND OPENLY SYMPATHETIC TO
THE KKK .
AND HE WAS CRITICAL OF
RECONSTRUCTION.
LESS THAN 60 YEARS
AGO, 1964 CIVIL RIGHT ACT
WAS OPPOSED BY 69% OF SENATE
DEMOCRATS SUPPORTED BY 82%
OF SENATE REPUBLICANS AND
OPPOSED BY 61% OF HOUSE
DEMOCRATS AND SUPPORTED 80
PERCENT OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS
OF THOSE WHO VOTED NO IN
HOUSE 74% WERE DEMOCRAT, AND
IN SENATE 78% WHO SAID NO
WERE DEMOCRATS
THOSE WHO FILIBUSTERED.
ROBBER BIRD.
AND BIRD SPOKE FOR 14 HOURS
IN A LAST-DITCH AFFORD TO
KILL THE BILL.
BIRD WOULD GO TOSERVE AS
SENATE DEMOCRATIC LEADER
FROM 1967 TO 89.
AND INCLUDING MAJORITY
LEADER FROM 77 TO 81.
AND 87 TO 89.
AND MINORITY LEADER 81 TO
87, HE WAS LEADER OF THE
DEMOCRATS FOR A VERY LONG
TIME IN THE SENATE.
HE WAS LONGESTS SERVING
SENATOR IN HISTORY OF
SENATE.
HE CAME ALONG WAY, BIRD.
AS A YOUNG MAN HE
WAS A CHIEF RECRUITER AND
ORGANIZER FOR THE KLAN IN
WEST VIRGINIA WHEN BIRD DIED
HE WAS PRAISED BY LEADING
LIGHTS OF DEMOCRATTING PARTY
RULING CLASS INCLUDING JOE
BIDEN, BARACK OBAMA, HILLARY
CLINTON AND THE REST.
AND SEVERAL CALLED HIM THEIR
GREAT MENTOR.
OKAY.
BUT THERE IS MORE.
JOE BIDEN AND EARLY TO MID
19 70S, SENATOR WORKED
CLOSELY WITH SOME OF THE
SENATE MOST NOTER TOIOUS
RACISTS, EAST LAND WHO
FOUGHT HARD AGAINST CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT OPPOSED TO PUBLIC
SCHOOL INY ITGRETION, SHOW
WAS JOE BIDEN, AND HE
BRAGGED ABOUT RECEIVING
PRAISED FROM LATE ALABAMA
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR GEORGE
WALLACE, ONE OF THE LEADING
RACIST, CALLED BIDEN ONE OF
THE OUTSTANDING YOUNG
POLITICIANS OF AMERICA.
BUT DEMOCRAT PARTY'S
GREATEST ICON WAS FDR .
LARGELY DUE TO HIS NEW DEAL
AGENDA, TRANSFORMED U.S.
AWAY FROM CONSTITUTIONALISM
AND CAPITALISM TOWARD
SOCIALISM AND CENTRALISM,
FOR THIS REASON, MORE THAT
BEEN DONE TO IMMUNIZE HIS
REPRESENTATION, 1942.
ROOSEVELT ISSUED EXECUTIVE
ORDER 9006 ROUNDING UP
MILITARY ROUNDING UP 120,000
JAPANESE AMERICANS INCLUDING
70,000 U.S. IS THES,
FORCIBLY RELOCATED TO
INTERNMENT CAMPS IN REMOTE
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
THEY LOST THEIR HOMES,
PROPERTY AND THEIR
LIBERTIES, IN 1944, IN A
CASE SUPERIOR COURT
UPHELD THE INTERNMENT ORDER
IN A 6-3 DECISION, AND BLACK
WRITING FOR MAJORITY LEAD
THE WAY UP TO HOLE THAT
DECISION.
NOW WHO IS HUGO BLACK?
BLACK ROSE THROUGH DEM
DEMOCRATIC
PARTY RANK FOR ALABAMA A
LAWYER FOR KLAN AND
RESIGNED FROM THE
KLAN BUT KEPT IN CONTACT
WITH THEM, AND OPPOSED THE
ANTILYNCHING BILL AND WAS A
SUPPORTER OF ROOSEVELT AND
AWARDED AS FIRST NOMINEE TO
SUPREME COURT, HIS RECORD IS
MIXED AND DISPUTED.
HE WAS AN ACTIVIST FOR
ROOSEVELT SOCIALISM HE
INSIST ON INTERPRETATION OF
THE BILL OF RIGHTS THAT
SAID, HIS SON.
STATED THAT KKK AND
DADDY HAD ONE THING IN
COMMON, HE SUSPECTED THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH, AND THOUGHT
THAT POPE AND BISHOPS HAVE
TOO MUCH POWER AND TOO MUCH
PROPERTY.
SO ROOSEVELT'S FIRST NOMINEE
TO SUPREME COURT WAS AN
ACTIVIST WITH THE KLAN, HE
WROTE MAJORITY OPINION
UPHOLDING ROOSEVELT'S
INTERNMENT OF
JAPANESE-AMERICANS AND
ESTABLISHED FEDERAL HOUSING
ADMINISTRATION, A PURPOSE
WAS TO INSURE MORTGAGES
PROVIDING HOMEOWNERSHIP, IT
FURTHERED RACIAL
SEGREGATION, IT DENIES
INSURANCE IN AND AROUND
BLACK NEIGHBORHOODS, THE
FHA WAS SUBSIDIZING BUILDERS
WHO WERE MASS PRODUCES
SUBDIVISIONS FOR WHITES.
WHEN THE REQUIREMENT THAT
NONE OF THE HOMES BE SOLID
TO AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
DID YOU KNOW THAT?
, RED LINING COMES FROM THE
DEVELOPMENT BY NEW DEAL BY
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OF MAPS
OF EVERY METROPOLITAN AREA,
WHERE YOU DO NOT GIVE THE
INSURANCE BACKINGS WERE
BLACK AREAS, THEY WERE
CALLED RED AREAS, HENCE TERM
RID LINING, ROOSEVELT
SLIGHTED JESSE OWENS IN
1936, HE WON MULTIPLE GOLD
MEDALS FROM MAIN 36 AND
BERLIN WERE INVITED TO WHITE
HOUSE WITH THE EXTENSION OF
JESSE OWENS, HE WAS ONCE
ASKED IF HE WAS SNUBBED BY
HITLER, HITLER DIDN'T SNUB
ME, HE SAID, IT WAS THE
PRESIDENT.
-- RADIOS VET SAID HE
OPPOSED LYNCHING AND LOBBIED
BY HIS WIFE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL BUT HE REFUSED, HE PUT
POLITICS AHEAD.
HE WOULD NOT SUPPORT FOR
SIGN A FEDERAL ANTI LYNCHING
BILL THAT WOULD HAVE TO COME
LATER.
THERE IS MORE.
ABOUT THE DEMOCRATS AND
ROOSEVELT.
EVEN TO THIS DAY.
BUT REPUBLICANS NEVER STOOD
IN ANY SCHOOLHOUSE DOOR WAYS
TO BLOCK LITTLE BLACK KIDS
FROM GOING TO SCHOOL WITH
LITTLE WHITE KIDS AND
REPUBLICAN NEVER SUPPORTED
SYSTEMIC VOTER SUPPRESSION
OR REPRESSION.
AS DEMOCRATS DID THEY CLAIM
TODAY.
THE REPUBLICANS NEVER
SUPPORTED JIM CROW, LITERACY
TESTS AND REST, EVER.
THE REPUBLICANS NEVER
SUPPORTED LYNCHING, THEY
PUSHED BILLED TO END IT.
THAT'S A PIECE OF HISTORY OF
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY, NOW,
BOTH PARTIES ARE IMPERFECT.
BUT THE PATTERN IN THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY GOES WAY
BACK, A VERY EVIL,
ANTIAMERICAN PARTY, IF THEY
WANT TO DISCUSS RACE
LET'S LEARN OUR HISTORY,
THEIR HISTORY AND DISCUSS
RACE, WHAT AMAZING ME WITH
WHAT THEY TALK ABOUT TEARING
DOWN CONFEDERATE SYMBOLS AND
BURNING BOOKS AND CHANGING
NAMES OF MILITARY BASIS, HOW
IS NAME THE DEMOCRAT PARTY
PERSISTS?
AND CONTINUES?
BECAUSE THEY CONTROL THE
CULTURE, RIGHT NOW, LET'S
TALK ABOUT ABORTION.
I HAVE NO PROBLEM TALKING
ABOUT ABORTION.
THE BIG PUSH FOR ABORTION
CAME AT BEGINNING OF THE
LAST CENTURY.
WITH MARGARET SANGER WHO
FOUNDED THE PLANNED
PARENTHOOD ORGANIZATION,
WHICH YOUR TAX DOLLAR HAVE
GONE TO IN BILLIONS TO
SUPPORT.
AND PLANNED PARENTHOOD AS
THEY SAY, SUPPORTS
ABORTION.
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT?
DEMOCRAT VOTED, SAID THAT
CODIFY RR-- CODIFY
ROE OR ANY OTHER POSITION,
WHAT DID THEY WANT TO DO,
THEIR BILL, WHICH MEDIA KNOW
AND THEY COVER FOR THEM
ELIMINATED PARENTAL CONSENT
FOR ABORTION, SUPPORTED
PARTIAL-BIRTH ABORTION TO
THE LAST SECOND OF BIRTH,
STEP ONES, THEY GRAB ONE OF
THE BABY'S LEGS WITH --
DELIVERS BABY BODY, UP TO
THE NECK.
THEY FORCE SCISSORS INTO
BASE OF THE BABE A SKULL,
OPENSES SCISSORS.
AND TO ENLARGE THE HOLE.
THEN TAKES A SUCTION
CATHETER INSERTED INTO HOLE
AND THE BABY'S BRAINS ARE
SUCKED OUT.
INCREDIBLE HORRIFIC PAIN FOR
THAT BABY.
RIGHT BEFORE BIRTH.
THEN THE CHILD IS REMOVED.
HAVING BEEN KILLED.
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY VOTED
IN SUPPORT OF, THAT I DO NOT
UNDERSTAND WHY REPUBLICANS
DON'T KNOW HOW TO EXPLAIN
THAT, WHO IS MARGARET
SANGER, THE GREAT FEMINIST.
POINTED OUT IN WASHINGTON
TIMES, SHE SHAPED THE
MOVEMENT IN AMERICA BEYOND
IN 30s AND 40s,
CONTRIBUTING TO
STERILIZATION LAWS AND 30
U.S. STATES, THAT RESULTED
IN OVER 60 THOUSAND
STERILIZATIONS OF VULNERABLE
PEOPLE.
INCLUDING PEOPLE SHE
CONSIDERED FEEBLE MINDED
IDIOTS AND MORONS.
SHE PRESENTED A KU KLUX KLAN
RALLY IN 1926 AND RECOUNTED,
THAT VENT IF HER
AUTOBIOGRAPHY, SAYING A
ACCEPTED AN INVITATION TO
TALK TO THE WOMEN'S BRANCH
OF THE KLAN.
I WAS ESCORTED TO PLATFORM,
AND BEGAN TO SPEAK IN THE
END, I BELIEVED I HAD
ACCOMPLISHED BY PURPOSE.
A DOES
LETTER IN 1939,
SHE WROTE:
>> HER OWN WORDS.
LEAVE NO ROOM FOR PARSING,
SHE WROTE MANY ARTICLES
ABOUT UGENICS AND JOURNAL
SHE FOUNDED IN "1917".
THAT REVIEW MORAL ASPECTS OF
EU.
>> AND PURPOSE OF IT.
BIRTH CONTROL.
SHE WAS A HORRIFIC RACIST.
NOT UNTIL A YEAR AGO.
THAT PLANNED PARENTHOOD AND
OTHER APOLOGISTS FOR SANGER
THREW IN THE TOWEL.
SAID YES SHE WAS A EUGENSIFT
.
LOOK HOW DEMOCRAT PARTY AND
RADICAL LEFT RUNS WITH IT.
79% OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
ABORTION ACTIVITY TAKES
PLACE IN MINORITY
NEIGHBORHOODS.
MOSTLY BLACK
NEIGHBORHOODS, THIS IS THE
HISTORY OF THAT ORGANIZATION
OF THE RADICAL ABORTION
MOVEMENT.
THIS IS THE HISTORY OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT RACE?